ما مدى أهمية هذه الانتخابات في اعتقادك الآن، نظرًا
لبقاء أردوغان رئيسًا والبرلمان
لديه أغلبية حزبية أه عندما
تنظر إلى أين يقع مع تحالفاته
بشكل فعال في رئيس الحزب أردوغان الذي
يدير كلاً من الرئاسة والبرلمان
ويمضي قدمًا
بشكل جيد، علينا أن  نعترف
بأن أردوغان هو مناضل عبقري
وفي الواقع منذ
وصوله إلى السلطة عام 2002 أه يمكننا
وصف حكومته بأنها
حملة دائمة كما تعلم أنه
يؤكد على التدين والقومية
أكثر فأكثر في السنوات الأخيرة أه كما  جزء
من صيغته السحرية للبقاء في السلطة
والاستماع إلى الكلام أه تعلم أنني
سمعت تبرئة ولكني رأيت أيضًا أه
تعلم أه إشارة إلى أنه الآن
يركز على أه وقال إنها على
وجه التحديد
أم التعافي
من إسطنبول التي كانت  خسر في
أه الانتخابات البلدية الأخيرة قال
2024 علينا أن نستعيد إسطنبول حتى تعلم أن
السيد أردوغان سيستمر أه على
الفور وللإجابة على سؤالك لقد
تغير أعتقد أه السياسة التركية
بشكل دائم أه الحملة الانتخابية
جرت بشكل أساسي في الداخل  ملامح
النظام السياسي الذي صممه
أردوغان ويحافظ عليه